I play any type of music I play the
Barney theme song and be in the party
like
and these are our Essentials let's go
[Music]
with this I can stay active no matter
where I'm at I could be inside I could
be outside you know I like to run but
some days I don't want to run and this
is also cardio you know what I'm saying
moving your arms yeah you're getting
your footwork right together you know
what I'm saying I put my music on when I
do this too all right I just love my
jump rope it does so much for me and I
think like in the span of one minute I
probably get 300 rotations Maybe 400.
but yes from like me I love my jump rope
man get you one man get you one if you
want to get in shape if you want to just
get back active and you don't want to
run you don't like doing cardio where
you're running or whatever you just
standing in place you know what I'm
saying there's many variations of jump
ropes right you have your ones like this
a speed rope you also have your weighted
jump ropes so I normally would have a
weighted jump rope but I was using it so
much one day I was I was jumping rope it
was a little crisscross yeah I don't
know I don't know I can jump rope let's
go go let's go whoa
shoot off the ground man push yourself
tequila oh wait let's go
this right here it's right huh this is
the device I use every day to transfer
my vocals into songs
for the world handy dandy Mike I just
plug it in
plug it into my computer we just float
you know I'm saying Jim might lay a hook
I might let hook just might let a verse
I'm laying reverse we add living this
like changed our lives forever shout out
to whoever invented the mic but who
invented the mic I don't know probably
somebody named Mike
one thing crazy about this particular
device called the microphone this was
part of the devices that we used to get
out of poverty this mic has taken us all
around the world it's taking us to
different countries it's taking us to
places we never thought we would go and
uh yeah this microphone is essential to
our whole entire life to my family's
life express yourself yeah
we're gonna have a lot of greatest hits
trust me we're gonna stage 75 like this
I'm getting old records getting sold
shout out to Emil burheimer Emil bird We
Appreciate You inventing this device you
change a lot of people's lives changed a
lot of people's lives you got a lot of
people heard Berliner family shout out
to the Berliner yeah
[Music]
this is my Essential Apple Max head big
giant extra large headphones I don't
know what they're called but yo I love
the headphones I never lose them they
work just like my airpods I used to buy
four pair of airpods a week that's a
thousand dollars I'm just feeding apples
they're just loving me but these
headphones right here they never fall
off my head I go running with them I
work out with them I sit down in the
chair and go to sleep with them on I
love these headphones out there
essential to me as you know we're about
to go on tour and um going on tour
you'll be on the road for long periods
of time during that time I just want
something to help the time go by and
when I'm listening to the music that's
one thing that helps the time go by and
you know these headphones like I said
they the best if you ain't got a pair go
get them after you see this go get them
right now get ease stop buying the
airpods apple don't be mad at me get e
true these are my gloves I got these
gloves when I was in Amsterdam actually
so they're really special and important
to me with my with my homie Joel green
we was training as you can tell Fitness
is a very important part of my life and
I just really love boxing boxing is my
way to um stay in shape to stay active
to stay young you know what I'm saying
these are my favorite gloves by the way
you tie them up these like my shoes too
I'll take them everywhere I go you know
what I'm saying do my gloves baby but
boxing teaches discipline consistency if
you want to get good at anything you got
to be consistent you know what I'm
saying so I just love it for that it's
not easy to do it's fun I like to work
out but I can't just go lift weights if
I go lift weights I'm gonna tire out
burn out of it I have to do something to
keep me interested so boxing is like I
guess basketball persuade is just
something that keeps me active
one of my essentials like I like Shades
and stuff crazy Shades these are like
montclairs but they're like goggles and
sun shades like sunglasses mixed in one
it ain't just crazy I feel like I'm on
the slopes but it just feels like so the
action pack is about to happen like when
I got these Johnson I just I don't know
something about them but I like all type
of different eyewears my favorite pair
right now is actually dior's the little
rectangle lenses with the CD on the side
those are my favorite ones or my chanels
like I got these chanels with the Double
C on the side with the uh Crossing Lines
on the side they're pretty crazy
sometimes I just like to hide my eyes I
mean I got a huge shade collection
um probably like 500 600 pairs like but
I don't lost 500 600 pairs too like the
CD Shades not for I bought like five
pairs already like
it's just great man one time I let my
monkey out she broke like 20 pairs of my
glasses I just came in my bathroom like
oh all half shades on the floor like
can't discipline I just said no no get
in the cage but yeah I couldn't even say
it like the glass already did
this next item man they ensure you a
happy future you know what I'm saying
they protect you even if I don't need it
it's just like it's good to have this
for your homies around they might need
one
okay
bro I call these friendship barriers I
feel like once you put on these it saves
the sanctity of the relationship with
the other person that you're using them
with once you take them off and you
decide to go unprotected things get more
serious so I like to call these
friendship areas we're gonna keep it in
a friendly place while we have these
things on I call it Willy Wonka golden
ticket because you're getting lucky if a
pull this out
foreign
this right here this beautiful creation
can make your day a whole lot better
it's a very important part of all my
days you know I wake up I ain't gonna
say I just brush my teeth in the morning
because I only wake up in the morning
sometimes I wake up at five o'clock
sometimes but I always brush my teeth
preferably two times a day my schedule
crazy like when I'm running to the
airport if I'm running late like my
mouth would just be like irritated if I
don't brush my teeth I'm like hurry up
and get your nearest thing and brush my
teeth wherever I'm at so it's like I
keep this in my bag just in case I have
I had a crazy start in my mornings boom
I can just go in the bathroom just brush
my teeth on the flight whatever I mean
you want to be smiling you know and say
you're going to be talking to people
you're going to be in people's faces
like you know that stinking breath
listen listen listen
everything
this is a lighter specifically a big
lighter we lit like big I keep this to
just to light candles you know like if
there's candles laying around I can just
come up and light the candles what about
the Mary Jane
[Laughter]
I was like I got a whole lot of clean
linen like candles I like the clean
linen scent like that's my favorite
scent or one of the melons clean linen
Yeah clean linen yeah that's fine that's
the candle yeah that's fine and the
clean linen Febreze Scent is like
top top
so this right here this my Tom's
deodorant you know I'm saying I live an
active Lifestyle the only thing like
you're gonna have to reapply this
like two times a day like and I'll be up
like really up 24 hours a day so it's
like I keep this on me like because
I don't want to be every stinking like
no matter what I got to read one day
like and I just read like some of the
ingredients that they put in like these
everyday products that we use every day
these chemicals gone in your body every
day
are we talking about not smelling man I
ain't gonna be using a lot of cologne
like I like to walk in it's part of my
outfit like cologne you gotta look good
smell good you feel good you know what
I'm saying so I put this on like
oh
it's like everywhere just be you know
what I'm saying smell it loud I get a
lot of compliments on the way I smell
like I personally remember you more on
the way you smell then how you look you
feel me so you can leave more of an
impact on a person like scientific fact
like
the most important thing is your brain
it's right up good head on your
shoulders our minds you know what I'm
saying we try to eat a good breakfast be
on point you feel me now I'm glad you
said that though because there's
definitely something we do take care of
as ourselves our bodies Our Minds the
most important thing you can take care
of in your whole entire lifespan is your
yourself your body your mind you know
what I'm saying so yes we don't leave
the house without a good head on our
shoulder what I did right huh can't be
the house without that man you did it
can't leave the house without my brain
it's gonna be a downward spiral thanks
GQ for watching these were our
Essentials we hope you enjoyed also make
sure you check out that new shrimp for
Life the new album streaming everywhere
oh
[Music]